maybe maybe you can relate to this
sometimes parents would say to their
kids
if you don't stop crying I'm gonna give
you something to cry about sure you ever
heard that statement yeah yeah okay so
the universe says if you don't stop
being grateful I'm gonna give you
something to be grateful for
so if you hang out in gratitude even if
you don't know what you want you can
hang out in gratitude then the universe
brings you something
in that vibration instead it shocks and
surprises you yeah so gratitude and that
higher frequency really really helps you
be in alignment with the law of
receiving how available am I to the
total givingness of the spirit there
there used to be a belief that it was IQ
that determines a person's success now
we know the Dozen you know Harvard did a
30-year study took the highest IQ people
entering the Harvard and other colleges
and then mapped them for 30 years and so
there was no correlation between high IQ
and happiness health or success there's
no correlation but there's something
what I call availability quotient when
you're available there's a you use the
word surrender earlier is surrendering
to something higher you're yielding it
doesn't matter what your IQ is your
availability quotient and your just your
your your gratitude you're hanging in
possibility thinking
provides the context the vibrational
context for more good to flow into your
life
you see and so it's not IQ it's AQ
every time your mind looks at what you
have
it'll start to the law will start to
become I have I have ten dollars I have
twenty dollars I have fifty dollars I
have a hundred dollars I have I have I
have until your your inner frequency
starts changing from I don't have to I
do have and then more is given
opportunities start to open up because
you're feeling that you are a hammer
opportunities start to open up that
brings more Prosperity more
opportunities for prosperity in your
life so you don't put it into the future
now
because we're just energy it's just
vibrating and we're just matching why
why is why is that so hard for people to
grasp
well people are in the conundrum of The
Human Experience they're they're daily
under assault by their own minds that's
been hijacked by fear
and then they are addicted to the fear
because of the toxic chemicals that go
through the body Temple there are people
that actually are addicted to the news
start as a chemical that's releases
cortisol it's release you know and it it
it debilitates the immune system it
stops you from thinking coherently you
get you enter into fight and flight it
messes up your blood pressure but people
become addicted they think they're alive
I have drama therefore I am you know so
there's a great addiction it's called
fear porn is society guilty for
perpetuating more of those things
happening because thoughts become things
the average person is just ignorant but
there are nefarious forces that want you
to buy things you don't need that
manipulate
so that there's greater fear or greater
sense of Doubt or a greater sense of
lack of self-worth unless you're wearing
this kind of perfume driving this kind
of car taking these kind of drugs to
alleviate your anxiety you know so
people use the power okay influence it's
called malicious hypnotism it's what
it's called
um they they become Adept at malicious
hypnotism so that there's certain levels
of angst that people live in and when
there's a certain level of angst people
are more easily controlled their mind is
more easily hijacked so we actually have
to take back our mind you said nefarious
so now I'm gonna have to go down that
rabbit hole I'm gonna go like wacky out
there a little bit like nefarious so I
feel like people are good to me in my
experience we're programmed by our
environment however there's also belief
that there are truly like evil nefarious
people perhaps even other entities like
controlling human beings
So when you say nefarious how far does
this go or where does this go beyond
humans
well when I met in the first I met
people that were so blind to themselves
they operate out of greed okay
stinginess manipulation control might
makes right there are people that live
like that and they're so cut adrift
from their from who they are that their
choice and decisions are totally ego
based it's not we it's a total I I'm
going to profit from this I'm going to
be successful I'm going to control you
know so this is so it's the fairies in
that sense okay in terms of outside of
the human uh species of course there
were beings to think otherwise would be
foolish you know I mean when you look at
now the new telescope that just came out
and you see trillions of galaxies you
know that exist you know the
somebody would be silly to think that
the Earth plane is the only plane where
there is life it is silliness there's
certain beings that are very highly
developed but they're underdeveloped
emotionally and so when they're doing
things they have no idea they're hurting
people it's not it's not a part of their
they haven't evolved at that level yet
so if in fact they begin to experiment
on somebody or it's you know things like
that they're not even in touch with the
fact that they might be scaring or
hurting that person so it's not like I
want to scare and hurt this person it's
like I don't it's like a sociopath it
doesn't have the capacity right so there
are beings out there I wouldn't call
them sociopathic but it's unevolved at
that level
you know we have people on the planet
Earth that are very empathetic
you know they don't want to cause pain
they don't want to feel pain they're
very emotionally mature
so to speak you see so yeah there's all
kinds of beings beings um that exist out
there and uh and some absolutely inter
interface with Humanity interface with
our government and things of that
particular nature I mean I mean I know
you know I know this like for a fact in
terms of people that I've worked with
you know so it's not like how does that
show up like when you say you know you
know for instance I knew I know a guy
he's passed over now
he worked with many presidents of the
United States his mother was a human
being his father was not and he was
extraordinary man he did so much to keep
people safe on this planet and he had to
deal with forces that weren't
necessarily operating for the highest
and best of all concern and sometimes
when things were happening on the planet
that were very terrible or about to be
terrible they him and his people had to
intervene he would call us together one
two three o'clock in the morning we'd
have to go into meditation in prayer wow
the whole Space yeah used a bomb oh they
did this or why they did that and he
would say to me if you ever see me in
public don't speak to me just pretend
you don't know me you know and that was
years ago he's gone on but that's that
that's one thing you know I've had other
experiences and I've had friends who've
had other experiences with these with
other beings the Western world is so
censored
is so censored the media is so censored
people just are ignorant about the
things that are so very in front of our
face so I would tell the human beings
every now and then just look up
I interviewed um John Paul De jorya a
few years ago now back when my podcast
first started and
um he started Paul Mitchell and Patron
and super successful entrepreneur he
told me during this interview it was not
anything that I was expecting
um based on talking to an entrepreneur
at his of his level
um but we got into aliens and
extraterrestrials and this was summer of
19. he said within five years we will
know that extraterrestrials are real and
it is 2023 yeah and we've had all this
stuff just go on recently with shooting
down craft and these Rando balloons and
whatever's going on
so is this the time
I think even more than that I think
besides those balloons people are seeing
sightings all over the United States all
over the world of these um crafts that
can stop and go stop and go up and down
and love Neil deGrasse Tyson I I think
he's amazing I think he's interesting
and smart but like when someone like him
says like but where's the proof I'm like
I don't know everywhere for years for
years I have a a friend that was um in
this service and he was on the uh ship
during the storm and he would see they
would see different crafts hovering all
the time they were told you can't tell
anybody what you see people like Neil
deGrasse who's that their intellect is
so high but in order to really go to the
next level you have to suspend the
intellect to go into your intuition
direct knowing and a lot of those people
can't do that they're they're inhibited
by their intelligence isn't that
interesting
if they can't smell it and taste it and
touch it and hear it it doesn't exist so
they are uh hindered by living only in
three dimensions you know so so they
they think they're not hindered but
they're in the world of Academia
you know in the world Academia has never
healed anything
it's linear right you have to go get it
right like it's just you know when you
get in tune with
get an alignment now you flip that
vertical and you're in alignment with
all potentiality but that doesn't make
sense to a linear person what about star
seeds crystal children benevolent beings
coming through humans or like the first
wave of volunteers second wave of
volunteers yeah whatever name we give
them
you know everything is evolving so the
Earth is vibrating
at a at a at a rate that's never
vibrated before it's it's worth is very
conscious so when you when you talk
about
um the different crystalline children or
whatever the
they're matching what's happening on the
planet as well so there's a there's an
evolution that's happening with Mother
Earth so the babies that are being born
are actually matching the next frequency
of the planet you know so you go back a
number of years ago people were heavy
materialists
spirituality then burst onto the scene I
mean not that it wasn't always here by
certain avatars and and followers but
you know early 80s it went to another
level and now
this conversation that we're having
right now this would have been really 30
years ago yes now it's accepted now it's
accepted it's to some people yeah but
you know it's accepted because the
evolution of Consciousness has happened
so yeah those beings exist they're
matching the frequency of the earth if
you like this clip and you want to hear
the whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen